you probably seek of this by now you're
like I've gone far enough down retinol
have an I'm just before literally just
before I walked into roll call
I had another flash min so I'm just
going to share it with you and if you're
bored of it then
alright I explain yourself happy with it
right because I'm doing a similar kind
of thing but I was like this is not a
true function what I mean this problem
we're solving is kind of different isn't
it okay so then I realized there is a
problem is what I'm trying to solve this
like so right and what I did was I took
this thing in this form and then I
squared okay so let me do that let me
show you what that looks like without
doing the substitution all right so this
is the original one no changes those
squaring their identities okay that's
one question if I'd solve that I'd be
okay but then I changed it
I said look let's change into this minus
2 sine X plus 1 and on the right hand
side I should have cos squared X right
okay now I already expect that these two
things are different when you square
this problem my question is why is this
so much your problem it's the musician
okay now I'm gonna try and bring it on
identity to explain it cos squared X
square X cos squared X has something to
do with the double angle formula last
year remember that because you can write
say cos 2x plus 2x
you can write that as cos squared minus
sine squared but you can also write that
as plus squared minus 1 minus cos
squared so I can write it like so that
okay so here's what's going on okay you
compare these two functions right the
period of sine is too much a period of
cos is 2 pi
but when you square everything the
period is no longer to my right what's
the period of this thing it's just pie
isn't it so in other words instead of
doing this okay so that's why you get
three points of intersection you're
going to get more of them squeezed into
a smaller space
it's Wiggly up and down more times so in
other words it was around more times so
it's got more opportunities to keep the
other graph that's what more solutions
are so if you have a look at this what
does that look like sine X minus 1
let's see here everything is shifted
down so from 0 to I think it looks like
this right that's sine X minus 1 and
negative cos x cos x cos x looks like
that it's on flipping upside down it
should look like this ok can you see the
three solutions you see 0 PI on 2 & 2 pi
okay but then if i graph this and what
is a look like it's quite different
because the cosine graph Wiggles more
times so and this guy's okay I'm going
to screw this up when I draw it but if I
think about sine X minus 1
I'm squaring this thing okay so minus 1
squared should give me 1 0 yet 0 squared
should give me 0 that's yeah
is minus 1 again so it's going to come
up to one this one will be minus two so
we're square it becomes like before
right and then you should come back to
minus one square it you should get one
so you get something like this oh this
is gonna I'm gonna get to there
something like that that's really good
you keep you down to a better job but
can you see one two three four solutions
okay so it was close enough right sorry
I don't know how your great so even
though when I saw this I was like oh
that's why because I don't know if you
if you're I mean you're like this method
seems okay why can't I use it I like it
don't tell me it's bad don't tell me
that one pot is bad and the rest of his
okay like it's just a random and
arbitrary why is it well here is why
okay so always be wary I mean it's the
same when you're solving inequalities
right you can't just square everything
and it'll be okay all right
that's why we learn tea results that's
why you thank you